we could get a new wave of jobs being
lost you know new technologies do cost
jobs
I don't think it's going to take
journalists or professional comedy
writers and certainly not poets yet
visual AIS can't do hands they always
get the number of fingers wrong
um text AIS cannot get meter or scansion
right they've got tells but for basic
copywriting for lots of stuff like that
for basic legal writing instructional
stuff these are going to be great that
could cost jobs you've also you know
we've the content on the internet
information costs a fortune to get you
know the spectators are a new site as
well as a magazine I work for these
things what happens when no one's
visiting the site and it's just a
feeding ground for a robot to present
information and say I think there's an
Almighty fight to come about what these
Bots do with news